canción a 2 esa es la situación de siete
funcionarios centroamericanos hoy
estamos agregando siete perpetradores a
la lista de eeuu de actores no
democráticos y corruptos bajo la ley de
compromiso mejorado del triángulo norte
que generalmente hace que los
perpetradores no sean elegibles para
visas y admisión a eeuu entre los
sancionados esta maria consuelo por ras
actual fiscal general de guatemala por
obstruir investigaciones sobre actos de
corrupción el patrón de obstrucción de
porras incluyó ordenar a los fiscales
del ministerio público de guatemala que
ignoraran los casos basados en
consideraciones políticas y socavar
activamente las investigaciones llevadas
a cabo por la fiscalía especial contra
la impunidad también sancionó a ángel
arnoldo pineda y la secretario general
del ministerio público guatemalteco por
los mismos motivos el salvador castigó a
cinco magistrados de la corte suprema de
justicia por socavar los procesos
democráticos entre los sancionados está
el presidente de la corte oscar alberto
lópez xerez
bukele el presidente salvadoreño
reaccionó en twitter contra las
sanciones queda claro que la lista no
tiene nada que ver con corrupción sino
que es pura política e injerencia de la
mas bajera estas sanciones se suman a
las impuestas a comienzos de julio de
este año cuando el gobierno
estadounidense acusó por corrupción a 55
funcionarios y exfuncionarios
centroamericanos entre ellos 14 del
salvador 20 de guatemala y 21 de
honduras entre ellos el ex presidente
hondureño porfirio pepe